this is the question i left you with
and it's a great question as questions
go let's just rewind a little bit and
catch people up so we know what's going
on before we leap into the mystery of it
this was where we began
okay
initial speed
we knew where the target was and we went
through we worked out all our time
equations
and then we worked out the firing angle
to hit the target in fact we worked at
the firing angles plural because there
are two just as a point of interest um
we ended up with this you solve your
quadratic you trade your sex squared for
a one plus tan squared and you get to
this point after you use the quadratic
formula right now
the point of interest that i have for
you is that i i
semi made up this question i mean
there's there's only so many projectile
motion questions that you can um conjure
up right so i made up these numbers and
when i got to this one i thought well
predictably you get something gross
because i just made up the numbers i
didn't craft them any with any care
and to my surprise you get some very
very
we got some very very nice numbers at
the end i expected to get something
awful with decimal places and so on
but they end up being 15 and 75.
strange okay
and then we thought that's that's kind
of sucks isn't it there's uh there's a
there's a relationship here clearly and
you can see that
here's my um actually i colored in
there's my my lower angle of projection
if you like there's the 15 degrees and
to get the 75 because 15 and 75 are
complements right i can put that other
angle well i didn't do the scale very
well but you get the idea
i can put the same 15 degrees up there
so if you like it's like i'm aiming
upwards 15 degrees
and then you hit the same target i can
go from the vertical aim downwards 15
degrees if you want to think about it
that way
okay then we posed this question we said
what happens if we raise the target and
we put it a kilometer in the air maybe
on top of a mountain or something like
that okay now again you get down to this
stage
and i think if my memory serves me you
get to this point you get tan alpha
being one or three is that right i think
that's right yeah
um and so you think okay again i've got
two angles
you've got now for one and an alpha 2.
but mysteriously
well we all know what tan inverse of 1
is it's
45 degrees okay
and then you get something weird and
awkward here can you give it to me to
the nearest minute it's 70
71 and
34 minutes sounds right okay good so you
look at that you think what's gone wrong
we expected something nice and neat some
kind of relationship and there is a
relationship it's just not exactly the
same okay
so the question is what is the
relationship here and how can i take
advantage of it in the future okay
um just to help you i don't know if you
ended up going further in doing this but
if you take these two scenarios and you
answer the same questions we did over
here if you resolve the final impact
angle and impact velocity you end up
seeing that this one when you fire this
it has
a horizontal velocity but no vertical
velocity right so it's not it's not
hitting upward it's not hitting downward
it's just hitting
level if you like so stationary point
for our equation apart okay so there's
your 45 degrees i'm actually not going
to draw anything else here um and then
you've got your 71 degree angle which is
i don't know something like this
there you go
and it hits either way
so the question was what was the
relationship and i gave you a clue do
you remember what was the clue i gave
you
i i drew in the hypotenuse didn't i um
something like this
it was uh clearly
clearly it was a badly drawn hypotenuse
because you're like i thought it was a
pretty wonky looking light now that was
my clue okay
the question is how does it relate
all right now to help you i'll walk you
through it and um you tell me when the
lights come on for you uh this triangle
here is well defined i know what all the
sides are and therefore i know what all
the angles are right for instance i've
got this side here being a thousand
right and this side over here being two
thousand so can anyone tell me
what's that angle of elevation in the
corner what is the angle of elevation
from the firing point
to the target how would i work it out
let's call it thea
if that angle's theta how do i work it
out
i think if i say i've got the opposite
and the adjacent side here right so i
can say
tan theta is opposite on adjacent
that's a half
right
so therefore i get you take tan inverse
of both sides now
a half that's not an exact value is it
i'm expecting something awkward but
that's okay let's just see what we get
what angle will it be someone going to
beat me there
26
26 and what
34 huh
that's suspicious
26 34
that's this angle in here
26
34
that makes me suspicious because i have
another 34 minutes over here in fact if
you want to go and have a look at tan
inverse of three and look at all the
trailing decimal places right and you
compare them with all the trillion
decimal places here
that doesn't seem coincidental okay
knowing that angle now does anyone want
to make a suggestion as to what they
think is going on
anyone see what's happening
you remember i drew in here
um my two 15 degree angles if you like
that gave me those two firing alpha one
alpha two okay
i've got some green angles in here as
well okay for instance
what's this angle
this is the difference
between the actual firing angle alpha
one right
and the angle of inclination what is
that
it'd be
alpha one minus theta wouldn't it
which in this case is 45 degrees minus
whatever that thing is what's that
no seriously what is that 18 something
1826
by my reckoning we've approximated right
1826 is that green angle
18 26.
can you see where else 1826 is
it's in the same spot it was before from
the vertical can you see it right here
if you can't do the calculation in your
head that's okay
i'll show you 18
26 because
90 degrees that's the vertical right
90 degrees minus alpha 2
right that's how far i'm inclined from
the vertical
that's going to be what was it 70 no
sorry 90 degrees
minus 71
34 which again is 18 26. okay so what
conclusion do you draw
why is it that these angles are not
complementary okay well you rightly saw
that well it's because i'm not on the
horizontal anymore but therefore how are
they related
how would you articulate that how would
you word it
because i i think we can come up with a
sentence right
that shows the relationship between
these two angles and the relationship
between these two angles is actually the
same
i'll give you a clue it's going to use
the words
equally inclined
and it's going to use the word
vertical
and there's some other pieces that we
need to put them all together
i want you to try and write one down
i'll give you 30 seconds or a minute see
if you can phrase what you think is
going on the relationship that you can
see there see if you can articulate it
okay
i won't scrutinize you i'll give you my
sentence
um i'm gonna use these phrases what am i
trying to relate together i'm trying to
relate together these two guys
alpha one alpha two okay in each case i
want to come up with a way of expressing
their relationship so that it holds no
matter which situation i'm looking at
okay so being the two things i'm
connecting are
f1 and alpha 2 they're the firing angles
aren't they
that's where i'm going to start
the firing angles alpha one
and alpha two okay
now they're related i'm gonna use this
phrase equally inclined right what that
means is um when you measure their
angles from certain places they'll be
the same though the places that i
measure the angles from will be
different okay so i'm going to say the
phi angles f1 and alpha 2
are
equally inclined to now
what are the things i'm measuring from
have a look at my
excuse me there's that frog have a look
at my green angles there right where
have i or how have i paired them up okay
well obviously one is from the vertical
okay in both cases they're from the
vertical okay but then the other one it
moves
what's the same what's the common line
between this line which is where this
lower angle is and this line the one
which i drew in a really wonky way
before what's the common thing between
them
uh you could say in a few ways i suppose
um you could either say you know it's
the angle of elevation here
it kind of works but it's a bit awkward
when there is no elevation right i think
probably the most succinct and
unambiguous way to say it is
equally inclined to
the line of sight that's what that line
is
isn't it that's the target literally
look sorry the origin your canon gun
whatever looking at the target line of
sight okay
ironically inclined to the line of sight
or from the lighter side
and
the vertical
or the y-axis
okay
so in other words
what i'm really saying is that where
where um
you've got 90 degrees that's your
vertical right 90 degrees minus that is
equal to
that minus now see this theta here right
this theta
in the first case was zero right and
that's why when i cover that when it
becomes zero aha i have complementary
angles see 15 75 okay
but if it's not zero if you're off at an
angle right
this will account for it there it is
right there okay 26 34 we had to work
that out in the triangle before over
here you don't have to because there is
no triangle okay so can you see that
this equation which represents this
statement holds whatever kind of
situation you'll get and you get this
double solution kind of business um in
projectiles all the time when you have
to find an angle to hit a certain target
okay